wow welcome to the wow
enroll the intro leave your entries in
the subreddit
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode of fly
hello everyone to everyone's favorite
part of the year
a week why everyone loved
let's just jump into it okay i'm ready
what have they posted on the reddit this
time youtube did an oopsy
ninja did an youtube flagged my fortnite
video
as bloody and gory and got demonetized
my fortnite video dude lol
how is that possible welcome ninjas
welcome ninja this is how it feels like
confusion
anger hatred just don't let it build up
inside you
towards some other channels and
ethnicities
i don't know why i added this okay you
know what let's move on
manga anime netflix adaptation
well god damn it looks strangely good i
i feel like i actually did a good job on
that edit even got the texture
i mean come on i should have made the
shirt more dirty
idiot it bothers me as well how they
didn't center the [ __ ] image like
jesus christ dude
somebody told me it's rewind time
everybody
i just realized if i sing the song it
might get demonetized
he is really good at photoshop he used
to create artworks before youtube fame
fun fact that's how i got started on
youtube i literally the first piece of
money i ever made
ever i just bought a computer
i guess you could say it's probably the
best investment of my life to be on this
damn
and here it is bethan as i call her very
nice
damn i was so proud of her that graphics
card very cheap
but very powerful i don't remember what
it was called god damn
that takes me back man jesus christ you
know i always grew up on laptops because
my family just wanted laptops for
whatever reason
but that feeling when you buy your very
first
desktop ain't nothing like it
no no no i fought in the great war i saw
man walk on the moon
i witnessed elon musk host meme review
and it was epic did you see the meme
about the deer
everyone omg elon hosted meme review
justin
am i a joke to you damn i well you were
a surprise though to be fair
justin although you have never expressed
anything
at all but there you go elon changes bio
famous for hosting meme review once now
i saw this meme before and yes i did
check
and yes i was disappointed but then i
realized maybe he had it
at one point when no one noticed our
final battle against t-series
friday's win pewdiepie oh god
you know it's still ticking and god damn
it is it close it wouldn't surprise me
actually think oh god maybe they passed
oh god i just realized when this video
goes up they're gonna pass
well i still have fridays with pewdiepie
never give up
should i run for president like these
fake elon
tweets it's like yeah it's fake right is
it fake did he do that
that's why it looks so interesting
because you never know you never know
what she's gonna do
this man has done the most to keep
beards on top if it wasn't for him
t-series would have passed long ago if
anyone deserves to be on meme review
it's him i couldn't agree more too bad
it's a bureaucratic issue right now
we're trying to figure it out but
don't hold your breath guys don't hold
your breath what have i started
treat people the way you want to be
treated you want copied strikes xd
we got him oh you're into demonetization
too
we got you covered baby this joke is
still
right well played
well played all right poor pokey listen
she copy strike one video i think
you get one strike warning it's just
like the strike system you get three
strikes so
i think she's okay here in india i made
a class
presentation oh god you made a class
presentation
on why pewdiepie is loved and how media
criticizes him teacher loved it by the
way this is first time i'm posting here
well welcome murphy141 and i see here
you says
1.8 meters which is exactly my height by
the way so i appreciate that you didn't
bring up media lies
okay elon musk when he sees a meme about
himself
elon musk when he sees a dancing i mean
it's true
i was kind of expecting him to enjoy
memes about himself more
you know these elon mosque memes i'm
like oh they're hilarious and then you
see them over yourself
felix smilberg it's not funny okay it
really isn't funny it's just cringy
i get it it's what i'm saying i
understand elon sand
moving on anime period this is so
insensitive it's okay just because i
don't have legs doesn't have to mean you
make fun of it
oh i thought beds are on my own audience
felix isn't our child beautiful
to the right send our baby to the crotch
they must fight for survival you want
fortnite
we got it oh you're into roblox huh we
got you covered baby
you want some minecraft easy this
channel
is still relevant even though t-series i
just realized has clearly passed me
how did they get such a boost but it's
just bots
i mean i it can't be any there's no way
there's box
look there even is a robot there i think
point proven okay
i have a trick up my sleeve and it's
coming okay
you best be scared t-series if it's not
all up already
keep an eye out because you're gonna die
okay that's not a threat
that's just a fact everyone's gonna die
at some point t-series actually good
shape
actually surpasses felix for a short
time
meaning that felix became number one
twice
just wanted to make it a little extra
guinness world record
no big deal no big deal at all if you're
subscribed to t-series we reply
thanks for your support complete your
donation now yay free reddit karma
did that actually happen well played
shaymin
oh lush sucks god damn that
is kind of uncomfortable but thank you
very much lush sucks as always
give lush suck some love link in the
description he does awesome work you
should follow him
oh here's a good one elon musk's hosting
meme review gave us a new meme format
it gave us plenty of new format let's
get real here plus they even recorded in
front of a green screen
absolute mad lads pewdiepie
i am one of the smartest intellectuals
on the planet
true straight up facts there is actually
a film based on this movie
now i gotta give myself credit for not
just saying this
not just for slipping through side
editing it but
also slipping through me and doing a
second edit on it
and then also slipping through me four
times watching it
until someone points i'm in the comments
that's how much of an intellectual i am
thank you very much if you remember this
you qualify
for a veteran's discount oh god we were
actually a million ahead at one point
where are we now i gotta look at it it
doesn't matter i don't care about
numbers by the way
i don't know if i said this but it
doesn't really matter like
numbers doesn't mean anything to me it
could be
50 billion it could be five i don't care
who's counting right
which count my brother and i did our
part
at the wwe smackdown sub to pewdiepie
well played you and your brother very
nice
i want to do something to summarize
everything that you guys have done
like i don't know like a video because
there's so many crazy
parts or legendary photos that i've seen
i would love to put that together
somewhere when t-series passes
no they will never my main man chara tv
got his video of him
singing to a hamster
demonetized i mean that seems
worthy of demonetization don't you know
children could watch that video
i need to see this video but then again
then i might get
demonetized well to be fair he hasn't
hit
request review and i'm sure if he does
they will actually
but then again i would like to know if
he did that and did it still get
demonetized
now me attack reverse uno
i don't have legs t gate hurt itself
in its confusion well played by me
thank you very much myself okay this man
is
77 years old has been uploading for 12
years
no way and he has only 131 subscribers
he uploads every week
he's a critic and reviews all the movies
oh god i gotta check this out
jackie k jet jack yeah
oh look they already subscribed and he
made a thank you nine year old army
that's so cute
he's already at 44 000 through the
subreddit hey i'm jackie k
cooper and this is my entertainment yeah
tim he has amazing quality of camera
how did he get such amazing quality
how does how does people have just
amazing quality of camera
i don't understand i really don't for
the week of february 17th
elita battle angel this movie was
written by
james cameron the titanic theme and
directed by robert
rodriguez okay straight to the point
short videos quick reviews
i like it subscribe okay well i'm not
like i will subscribe
why the f is there a t-series logo on my
pewdiepie
chair for only 3.99 for only 3.99
that is a great price by the way and i'm
glad you recognized that
and the t is there i don't know okay i
really
don't know god why they're everywhere
they have taken over our chairs that's
how you know they've already won
i'm living in a blissful moment right
now the calm before
the storm but i got like i said i have a
few trips up my sleeve
but that's it for life for now we're
just gonna have to see what happens
stop crying it's gonna be okay
all you have to do to feel better about
yourself is to buy
all the merch five copies each limited
time only
thank you guys for watching another
video smash like if you enjoyed and i'll
see you guys
tomorrow brofist not yet very soon
brophy is coming soon what tuber
simulator is becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes
ah this game is still relevant
god dammit
you